[Music]
[Laughter]
the NHS we could give it to the NHS we
could spend it on education we could
spend it on defense that we do pay in
350 milligrams gross every week so it's
not Elijah's tell me how we do public
services are going to be off the cliff
how much is it
[Laughter]
trees amazed a crime minister and that
we that we have a Conservative
government at the moment they may or may
not agree with that but most people know
nobody knows how many people know who is
running the European who's in charge of
commission who's in charge of partner
with political parties right question
you on the Treasury published figures as
to what would happen yes my government's
Treasury published figures as to what
would happen if he voted to the apology
there but if you voted and those figures
were wrong when they
[Applause]
I've seen your government says Mary Shaw
economy is going to be it's going to be
16 percent 16 percent impact and they
commonly the Northeast which is already
hard is it I have a youth unemployment
rate there's to lose our aerospace
industry and my constituents who work
hard in manufacturing didn't vote for
this they didn't vote to ISIL they
didn't lose their jobs they didn't vote
in equality you didn't see the North
even a minute figures that came out of
the Treasury I'll check my phone you
carry on thanks for joining us we really
very much
walk in front of the camera excellent
sorry Anna so you were talking to me
about heat you know he has some serious
points to make